[Música]
o sol o vento mais um vídeo e hoje eu
vou ensinar como fazer uma música com
marcas criam bastantes mais comentários
que aqui está ela finalmente estamos
contendo três projetos por conseguir
fazer isso de maneira bastante amplo e
desta forma você consegue fazer em casa
também vai fazer gols e dar dedicação
papel cola fita cola quanto os dois
lados e os clipes tinha em tour que vai
ser mais complicado até mesmo um touro
porque eu tentei um pouco força para
puxar um fio internamente estiverem
vários condutores você deve fazer é ir
testar 11 eo níquel tem mais força do
que estarmos em uma crônica aqui que eu
pessoalmente acho que não serve para
nada - só atrapalha quando alguns isto é
também preciso deixar assim em rima
esteticamente fica muito bonito desta
forma a arma só funciona quando vocês
colocam carregadores dentro rio para
retirar os fios na hora de descarregar
você tem que ser um carregador vocês
forem crianças passam o produto porque é
muito mais divertido e seguro para vocês
não é brincar nem óculos de proteção e
vamos tentar bater os três milagres v ou
seja talvez que conquistemos - lights
doce um vídeo e influenciou bastante
criar conteúdo no youtube não é afiar
outros educado de conteúdo que existem
aqui falar e levar o troféu para lá
[Música]
o
uns
[Música]
eu estou sendo fim espero que vocês
tenham gostado desse projeto será uma
questão é se os comentários que vai
tentar fazer coisas que vocês esperem
mais como é o caso desta arma incrível
discutindo tanto que eu acabei por fazer
em sobretudo por ter sido obrigado pelo
vosso apoio usando o nosso site
a digital ela ficava o físico dos demais
uma casa chegando é gum